let's just have a recap of of what we
know through open source intelligence
and satellite imagery about the russian
buildup uh on the ukrainian border that
deborah was talking about so
in terms of the russian border itself
there are a number of units that have
moved much closer to it
and are now starting surrounded of
course there's a lumber in crimea as
well which
russia annexed back in 2014 you remember
there is a unit as well unit or two in
moldova
and then well those numbers are around a
hundred thousand then we have the
exercises that are ongoing in belarus
and you can quite
clearly see there
that kind of picture of encirclement if
you like
around ukraine
the other thing that i would point out
is the black sea fleet
down here based in sevast sebastopol
in crimea used to be pretty decrepit
about 20 years ago
but they've undergone two decades of
massive investment they were pretty
crucial actually when crimea was annexed
in stopping ukrainian warships from
getting back to their base and it could
be
if there was an invasion uh that they
could play some sort of role uh either a
long-range uh missile type role or
perhaps
uh and you've got the uh the ukrainian
port of odessa around there one of the
key ports
key maritime ports for ukrainian imports
and exports perhaps they could play a
role around that i just want to
highlight on a satellite image
uh one piece of russian equipment
and this is the s-400
nato call it the growler it's an air
defense system uh that most analysts
think is pretty much the best in the
world and so this gives russia uh
coverage of the airspace wherever they
place it with around a 400 kilometer
radius
and gives them a defensive system
against any uh foreign or enemy aircraft
so if we go back out to
the larger map i can show you where they
place it that is a satellite image
that we just showed you
of that system uh based
uh around there in the sort of southern
centre
of belarus we believe there's also a
similar system uh just over the board
from kharkiv uh in russia here and one
down in crimea
so assuming that
fact is correct
what it means is that and this is rough
but if you think of a 400 kilometer
radius around all of these
it gives russia
control or at least awareness
of a large part of airspace over ukraine
so
when people talk about things like um
patrolling the skies and getting nato to
have a no-fly zone that makes it far
harder to carry something like that out
and one final thing that i'm going to
put on here are the positions of
nato forces
around the region so you can see
that it's not necessarily russia having
it uh its own way of course it's only
right to put in ukrainian forces as well
around 200 000 uh ukrainian regular
forces
large uh but
minuscule when you compare it to
the size of the russian forces and as a
final point despite the fact that you've
got this massive buildup of the russians
all around here and that's as i said at
the beginning this of the open source
satellite intelligence if you like or
videos that are appearing on social
media the forces we know about of course
if the first shots are going to be fired
uh in this potential conflict it might
not come from traditional hardware at
all it could be what we now know is
hybrid warfare so
cyber attacks for example against
critical infrastructure in ukraine um
perhaps the little green men that we
remember back in 2014 in crimea it might
be that the russians don't use
traditional military means if they
decide to exacerbate a conflict with
ukraine